good afternoon
my name is jesse benall and i'm counsel
to the trump campaign
donald trump won the state of nevada
after you account for the fraud and
irregularities
that occurred in the election this
afternoon
we have filed a contest of the election
in carson city district court and
we are asking the court to recognize the
fact
that president trump was victorious in
this election
i'm going to go ahead and hand it off to
matt schlapp
thank you jesse
today is an important day about trusting
free elections in america as we have
gone through this process since
election day we have been guided by
facts math and science
every american needs to trust
what happens when we vote and especially
the 73.3 million
americans who voted for the president
they deserve answers they need
transparency
and they need it right now
in all my years in politics
i have never seen the types of voter
irregularity
we have seen in clark county
the zeal to push reckless unsolicited
mail-in voting resulted in 50 percent
of ballots coming through the mail in a
ten-fold increase
in mail ballots in clark county
fact the voter lists were never
appropriately scrubbed including the
press reports
after foia requests of not
scrubbing over 80 000 primary voters
before the general election ballots
were made fact
illegal ballots never should have been
mailed
and they never should have ended up in
the final tally
how did this happen this happened
with a reckless change in nevada
election
rules right before the general election
which reduced the democratic norms
of meaningful observation by the media
and by americans the reduction of ballot
security
and almost the elimination of signature
verification
nevada and clark county have created
this crisis reckless
unsolicited mail-in voting
has created this crisis
there have been so many volunteers since
election day many of whom were here
today many more
could not make it because they continue
to work night and day
to expose the truth that's what we're
guided by
the truth be it something we want to
hear
or be it something we not want to hear
we don't like
discovering the historic level levels
of voter irregularity for all these
volunteers for all these lawyers
both in nevada and around the country
who have been attacked
who have been doxxed who have lost
professional opportunities
all for standing up for just
transparency of information from the
government
to her citizens we honor you
to the whistleblowers over a dozen here
in nevada and growing
and to the whistleblowers around the
country
we thank you we admire you
we stand with you we have talked with
you
about the threats that you fear you will
face
for simply trying to point out
the wrong doing and the illegality
that you observed and to my fellow
americans
i think we all know this and have this
in common
we would love to heal and to unite that
cannot happen
until the truth is revealed until the
facts
are known until people have answers
to their questions and adam laxalt is
going to walk through
those facts in this case
[Applause]
good afternoon everybody so
today is an important day for nevada
over the last 10 days or so
the media has continued to ask for the
evidence
of the irregularities that we found in
this election
in fact some media already concluded a
few days ago that there was no
fraud presented and
i need everyone to understand the
herculean task
that we face to try to from the outside
of a system
help shine a light on the irregularities
in this system we don't own the system
we aren't part of the system
there are no former fbi investigators
there's no former team of attorney
general
pi investigators these are people that
are volunteering these are people that
have given the last few weeks of their
lives
trying to run down the complaints we've
received
from across the state everyone
has some experience
in the last few weeks that leaves them
some
doubt about whether this election
was conducted freely and fairly a number
of you
in the media i spoke to off the record
that said people in your
in your uh newsrooms had extra ballots
mailed to their homes
or they felt that someone else had had
potentially cast the ballot
on their behalf these are stories that
poured in
and again we're trying to take an
imperfect
system and do our best to shine light
so it's an important day for nevada
because this
lawsuit is bigger than
whether the president won nevada or
former vice president joe biden won
nevada this lawsuit
is about taking this collected effort
this collected work
and presenting it in an election contest
and let me just say that
many people started complaining in
august
when this system was fundamentally
transformed
the concerns of the radical
transformation of this election
were put in op-eds they were put in news
interviews
they were put anywhere people would
listen
and these concerns ended up
bearing true now what are the
what are the primary concerns of what we
face
we converted to this wide scale
mail-in balloting election
as was already recounted we had a lot of
improper
ballots being mailed to people's homes
and apartment buildings
and across the valley now
we were told that the much vaunted
signature verification process would
cure any potential
for someone to take a loose ballot
to fill out who who they would vote for
and sign the envelope and mail it back
in
what we are providing today in this
lawsuit is that
many of these votes
were improperly cast
we are presenting today in our formal
contest
that there are north of fifteen 000
people
who voted in nevada
and another state we are presenting
that people voted in people that had
already done a change of address and
left this state
outside of 30 the 30-day requirement
their ballots
were still cast we are also presenting
dead voters now
it's important for everyone to
understand
we don't get to pick up the phone and
call the registrar and say we
think we've found a dead voter will you
confirm or deny this is a dead voter
there's nothing in this process that
allows that
and i encourage you to ask joe gloria
as he said in press conferences there is
no
forward investigatory process
in the clark county voting system there
is no one right now
in this system that is combing through
voter rolls
and is looking for dead people that may
have voted in this election i hope
everybody understands that i hope
everyone
accepts that as fact they are a
complaint based system so an individual
has to
complain that they think something
happened and then even then joe gloria
says
those complaints are forwarded to the
secretary of state's office
so i will only leave one example
if a person has died and that ballot
was mailed to someone's home and someone
voted that
that ballot who is going to complain
about that vote cast
no one quite clearly so the system
isn't investigating these things and so
we've brought forward these classes of
voters
now what are the other class of voters
that we think
make up the number that that puts this
presidential election in jeopardy
the mail-in ballot system which in clark
county was
upwards of 500 000 votes
started with a machine
this machine was the first
pass for signature verification
okay now we've spoken to experts
and this is part of our lawsuit we've
spoken to many
what they call ai experts and computer
vision
experts and what you will find
is that this machine doesn't have some
large professional body
an election integrity body that has
certified
this machine to be used to verify
signatures
okay you will also find
that in clark county they took
the factory setting and they adjusted it
to 40 percent of a signature match
now what these people will say is
once clark county took that factory
setting
and they manually adjusted it
it makes the results
of the signature match unverified
and something that cannot be relied upon
they will also say and this came out in
one of our hearings
the clark county elections admitted in
hearing that the factory setting for
this machine
wants a particular quality of photo
image
to match and so any of you
that signed your ballot and sent it
through this machine
your signature is this high quality
photo image now what they said in court
is that the signature that they're using
to match
came from the nevada system and that
signature that photo quality was
well below the 200. so we have two
different
reasons why the matches of
north of 100 between 130 to 200
000 signatures that were verified with
this machine
are not reliable these are the classes
that we are presenting to this court
these are the classes that we believe
are in jeopardy for this particular
election and next i want to turn to
jesse to go over
at least a few other irregularities that
are in the lawsuit
thank you adam of course meaningful
observation
is key to any free election system
worldwide being able to have observers
watch the whole process is something
that goes to the heart
of any democratic republic we didn't
have that
through too much of this election
process it was done in the shadows in
the dark
also provisional ballots were handled
irregularly and different voters
were treated differently depending on
what polling location they went to
and when they went there giving some
people the right to vote
and taking that right from others
you had unfortunate situations where
there was schemes set up
to give voters something of value
raffle tickets t-shirts other things
like that if they would come
and vote something that violates federal
law
something that violates nevada law
what's worse
and that you don't even have to prove
this to show that it's unlawful
is that same campaign that paid people
to vote were encouraging people to come
out and vote
for the biden harris ticket
you had a lack of security in too many
of the systems for voting
making it far too susceptible to bad
actors
and the bad actors came
the fraud came we have
we have one eyewitness one whistleblower
who actually saw people filling out
ballots at buying a biden harris fan
this fraud these irregularities
cannot stand in a free society
it takes in dilutes the votes
dilutes the rights of nevadans and
americans
who should all have an equal vote
and that's what this campaign is is
doing that's why we are here
we want every legal vote to count
we want full observation and
transparency and we want
to hold accountable now a system
that was right for fraud and allowed
that fraud to come
and that's why we're going to court
we'll be able to take a few
jesse you questions off the press
conference by saying that donald trump
warned about it
yes do you plan in this lawsuit to give
specific evidence
names addresses of some 35 000 voters
that need to be a margin that you would
need
to prove we are going to give evidence
in
and we have evidence of in
in various different forms
of uh of irregularities and fraud in
this process
that span that gulf between
vice president biden and president trump
to show
that the irregularities are such
that the the media's declaration that
joe biden
won nevada is wrong and president trump
was indeed the victor of nevada we have
declarations
yes we we have we have
declarations from
over 400 people just so far
nevadans that
go to the fact that these irregularities
and
and this fraud existed and we are going
to put on
evidence admissible in a court of law
and let a court see
what actually happened here
yes sir so this is a a state court
action because it's an election
in here it contest like you're making
some of the same arguments for me before
judge wilson
how do you plan to get her is this a
different case you're presenting
regarding me
or is it the same it's a different case
with different parties and different
issues
um and you know one of the one of the
issues that already was
was previously um uh considered by by
the court is is whether the plans in
that case for instance had standing
and so you know there there will be a
number of legal issues decided but we're
we're quite confident in the fact that
when the law and the facts are clearly
adjudicated in this matter that it will
be very clear
that once all the the voting happened
once once everything occurred the
results were
unreliable because of the irregularities
in the
i hear you fraud a couple of minutes ago
say voters were paid to vote for
brighton
specifically voters were given something
of value to vote
a raffle ticket uh items of clothing
the raffle tickets were for cash cards
and that's something that's clearly
against the law to give someone
something of value to vote
and then on top of that the same
campaign
that was doing the raffles that was uh
you know giving giving people shirts and
cash cards and everything else like that
also said uh you know to
encourage people wearing biden harris
paraphernalia
encourage them to come out and vote
for but for the biden harris ticket
uh it's a campaign that's that's fully
um explained
in in the lawsuit um it it happened all
over the country but
and we can get you more details
specifically on that
think i think we can take one more and
then we'll be available later for any
specific questions
in the process of trying to get this
information from voters and how are they
identifying themselves
we are using and we have put thousands
of man-hours in this
at this point as mr laxalt has already
explained
having volunteers and
and workers go out and verify the data
that we've been able to
to collect and we're going to do
everything we can in a very short amount
of time
and so far it's been without any
investigative powers you know is that
none of the investigative powers that
law enforcement would be able to uh to
do and we've been able to verify
so many instances so far of fraud and
irregularity
thank you all so much
um